en tout cas ce qui ressort de cette
commission depuis le début de la semaine
c'est qu'il est de plus en plus
difficile d'assurer l'avenir des médias
d'information en région les difficultés
de capital médias en sont une
illustration
mais le défi financier est grand aussi
pour d'autres types de médias en radio
par exemple sylvain chamberland et pdg
d'arsenal médias qui compte quatorze
stations de radio notamment à
lac-mégantic victoriaville saguenay
matane et ailleurs sylvain chamberland
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur venir diriez
vous que la radio commerciale régionale
vie à peu près les mêmes difficultés les
mêmes défis que les journaux régionaux
certainement des défis importants
évidemment les défis sont différents
parce que je dirais que la technologie
est dans la radio à des gens quand même
déjà pris un virage je dirais plus
rapide que par exemple les journaux ou
même la télévision à cet effet la
famille dit un média plus les juges peut
le dire de cette façon l'homme par
contre le défi publicitaire demeure
entier tout le monde ça brûle roues même
source donc c'est pas sympa évidemment
vous avez dit hier en commission que vos
stations étaient rentables que votre
entreprise était rentable et même que
vous continuer d'acheter des stations
encore en début de semaine votre modèle
semble fonctionner mais vous exprimer
quand même des inquiétudes sur la
viabilité des médias régionaux
est ce que votre modèle est fragile le
modèle est définitivement fragile et en
fait effectivement qu'on continue parce
que je pense que quand on a comme dans
notre cas établi une façon fonctionné on
a décidé d'aller de l'avant il plus
question de reculer par contre
effectivement que le modèle est fragile
et c'est certain qu'en ce moment il ya
quand même des questions importantes
qu'on a d'ailleurs posé au gouvernement
hier
oui et là vous parlez beaucoup
d'investissements de la part du
gouvernement de dépenses publicitaires
du gouvernement est ce que ça passe par
ça principalement réinvestissement en
publicité dans les radios commerciales
locales par exemple où exactement mais
moi je pense que c'est une première
étape avant de comme on dit est un
éléphant ça se mange une tranche à la
fois je pense qu'au moins on faisait ce
premier point là et que le
le gouvernement client qui est quand
même important et qui a pas la même
équipe a le même client que n'importe
quel autre client doit s'assurer de
d'être responsable dans ses placements
publicitaires et c'est pas juste une
question de chichis pour dire vous en
mettez plus ici passer l'eau peu importe
le gouvernement a une responsabilité
d'avoir un message équitable pour tous
les citoyens du québec et à cet effet là
je pense qu'il serait normal que par
exemple quand on fait une campagne sur
la sécurité au volant et qu'on veut
mettre 2 par exemple la pression sur le
fait du port de la ceinture de sécurité
je comprends pas que ça ne passe pas par
exemple partout dans toutes les régions
du québec
et ça ça passe par gogos ça passe par
facebook et ça passe par les grands
groupes également que son coach déco est
belle oui il y en avait plus et
publicité là exactement en fait de dire
moi fait on les a jamais eu c'est plutôt
comme ça que j'allège l'aborderont dans
notre très très peu quoi exactement
on a très très peu sauf qu'à un moment
donné c'est sûr que cal attaques
publicitaires se séparent pic des joies
au dg américains qui viennent y mêler
les cartes encore plus
moi je pense qu'à ce moment là le
régional est complètement écartée alors
que ce devrait être l'inversé
la priorité devrait d'investir d'abord
dans les régions du québec
et oui on investit à montréal et québec
mais les gens sont surexposés aux
messages particulièrement montréal et
moi je pense que le gouvernement a une
responsabilité cet effet le déformer
tous ses citoyens
justement et vous êtes d'accord avec
l'idée d'une régie publicitaire donc un
regroupement d'entreprises qui
pourraient gérer de la publicité face à
quoi face aux grands géants du web où
exactement en fait je pense que la régie
publicitaire particulièrement pour le
monde internet
je pense que pour le numérique les
petits groupes indépendants auraient
avantage à travailler ensemble à un
moment donné on est quand même
et j'aime d'ailleurs l'idée que radio
canaux qui peut s'appuyer cette démarche
d'une autre façon mais ces claques les
grands groupes qui ont du volume comme
quebecor comme
radio-canada évidemment peuvent surtout
su fait et s'organiser et pas
suffisamment de volume et les petits
joueurs comme je pense aux devoirs jeu
pendant mes deux groupes spécifiques
mais le droit par exemple arsenal média
ou des plus petits groupes de radio par
exemple à québec aurait avantage tout le
monde a travaillé ensemble pour avoir
une régie publicitaire par une meilleure
force de frappe auprès de nos clients
ici au québec mais vous n'êtes pas
d'accord qu'on est directement capital
médias comme on vient de le faire il ya
quelques jours pourquoi mais moi ce que
j'ai dit en fait c'est que je suis pas
d'accord avec l'aide d'urgence pour moi
puis j'écoutais monsieur bernier à
quelques secondes heure auparavant et je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec lui j'ai
une question de rendre des comptes aussi
on peut pas passer on peut pas arriver
dire jr 10 millions vers 5 millions gers
10 millions c'est une désinvolture pour
moi qui vraiment ne cadre pas avec l'âge
comprend l'action une urgence et tout ça
mais ces éclats convient pas d'apprendre
soyaux il ya cinq minutes que le média
est en faillite jeudi
on voit venir ça donc pour moi j'aime
les actions réfléchies
j'aime quand on prend le temps de
réfléchir aux choses et qu'on prend le
temps de décider que va-t-on faire dans
l'avenir la commission tombe à point
nommé
d'ultimes à cette nouvelle a aidé à
mettre la crise des médias à l'avant
plan et c'est très bien mais comme
j'expliquais milliards au gouvernement
je pense que l'on doit avoir des acteurs
des médias qui viennent accompagner le
gouvernement pour l'aider à faire les
bons choix et ensuite le gouvernement
décidera ce qui est le meilleur pour
pour la sueur des gens qui vous oubliez
aussi cette idée de créer une agence
d'information télé québec
voyez-vous radio canada aujourd'hui dit
on veut partager du contenu si une
agence d'information télé québec faisait
la même chose ce sera pas intéressant
pour un groupe comme le veau mais en
fait ouais ben bella faudrait avoir la
forme que ça prend ce ces nouveautés
bébé encore là c'est radio canada qu'il
fait pour télé-québec a fait ça existe
même pas pour l'instant mais pour moi
est ce que j'exprimais ya ou suite itier
c'est que la première le premier réflexe
en fait devrait être celui des affaires
publiques
ça coûte extrêmement cher les psys les
petits médias comme nous avons pas
certainement pas les moyens de faire des
grandes affaires publiques et moi j'en
suis de dire on finance par exemple des
organismes de presse qui vont mettre
beaucoup d'énergie par exemple dans les
affaires publiques et honnêtement
j'étais jolie diyar commission hauteur
radio canada que par exemple télé québec
pour assurer ce rôle là un rôle de
rempart pour s'assurer qu'on a un
minimum de très bonnes informations et
d'affaires publiques dans nos médias et
ce pot on peut pas être perdant cet
effet là mais de l'est de les amener
dans les formations quotidienne on
change de registre un émoi chez pas sûr
que c'est sur la voie qu'il faut
utiliser que sylvain chamberland merci
beaucoup merci beaucoup monsieur finir